no I think the problem with me was when  I went to UNI and I came out of my  traditional or my culture bubble the  bubble so I think that bubble protected  me for so long and I wish I stayed in it  a bit longer because the trauma only  came when I thought oh let me experience  a bit now I don't know I feel like I'm  managing the situation well compared to  what Society will tell me because  there's a lot of people that will tell  me why are you even investing any more  time or why even allowing this Dynamics  because a lot of people say OH Close  book and rush out yeah that's why girls  give the worst advice yeah I I don't I  don't think you could say you're  managing it well unless you're still  with her can I just no it's like it's  it's not you can't it's like that's like  that's like like failing a test and  saying you guys